[Music]
so we have
a hypothetical situation where we have
discovered this chick weight data set
that exists built into R it's one of the
built-in data sets so we have trick
weight you know Scott wait time chick
diet
um and maybe we've made some plots did
that stuff so you know we look at chick
wait over time
nice line plot maybe we've looked at the
density and we say you know I want to
build a
shiny app with this you know I've got
these nice uh plots and I want to put
them in a shiny hat but I'm dreading
that aspect of going in and setting up
that whole uh UI uh because that's just
the code that I haven't written before
it's annoying to remember how to write
it so that is a kind of a use case that
the UI editor is attempting to make it a
lot easier so we can go in uh in this
project that we have that's empty except
for these chick plots dot R script that
has those plots you know we load the
shiny UI editor and then we say launch
editor and we give it this application
we call it chick Dash plots and you'll
notice we don't actually have chick Dash
plots in here and what it's going to do
is recognize that it doesn't exist yet
and ask you a few questions about
creating it so you say uh you know I
want to start a new app from a template
choose which template right now we don't
have that many so we're going to do a
single file template that is the geyser
app run that and now the UI editor is up
and running and it's running just this
simple
geyser app uh just with two plots
instead of the typical one but it's a an
app that you are well familiar with so
we can actually go in we see now that
there is Dash plots in here we can click
into that and we see an app.r and we can
open that up and this is the code that
the UI editor is currently running and
so
we can see that if we want to change
stuff like say we have our header here
and it is expanding the whole top we
drag it over here
it updates and we see now the header is
only spanning the First Column there and
so any update that you make in the UI
editor is automatically updated
in the app code itself
so that's nice but what if you wanted to
actually like you know adjust what is
being plotted uh you know a lot of this
fun stuff in shiny apps is doing the
plots and so we already have render
plots here for this plot and blue plot
and so what we can do is take some of
our chick plot data
and grab this code
and replace in our app.r this disk plot
at code and we can save it
and you'll see that there's an error we
can check this it says okay I could not
find function
Judy plot so we actually need to load
ggplot so say library
what to save that another error
object check not found
um so let's go back in here one more
time
filter oh this is a classic error
filter is one of those functions that
exists in the player and also in the
base so we need to actually explicitly
load you higher
and now we've been making these changes
directly to our server looking at the
errors that are coming through in the UI
editor and now we actually have that
plot up and running in our app and so
one of the things we probably want to
change is to not be this plot so we're
going to call this you know
weeks
so we've updated now it's not there
because it's looking for the plot output
of Weights which we don't have because
we haven't renamed it go here rename it
to wait save it and it's back and so we
can continue doing this for a bunch of
different things so let's go take this
distribution plot here and let's replace
the blue plot with that
that paste it there save it
they're there a little bit confusingly
called Blue plot even though we have
some orange red distribution so let's do
the same thing here call this
distributions or maybe call it dist
once again it's gone let's go fix it
[Music]
save it
it's back
so you can see that we could just
continue to make our changes here let's
call this
chick Waits
Center
and code is continuing to update so one
thing that we might want to do also is
we have this number of bins later which
isn't doing anything for us right now
but we do have uh we're filtering to a
given number of chicks in this case it's
six
so what we might want to do is take this
slider and repurpose it to decide that
uh filter number for us so let's change
it to numb chicks
[Music]
call it
chicks two bucks
and I don't think we have that many
units maybe set them into One Max two
and start at a value that is reasonable
say five
and let's set a step value
um so we don't have incremental let's
say step value at one so we can go in
here we see that we actually have this
slider up and running but it's not
hooked up to anything but we now know
that we have created an input ID of num
chicks we can just copy that come over
here say input in
put dollar sign numb chicks place that
copy this get rid of that because we
don't need it anymore save
so in theory this will now change
but
uh the classic Factor problem is getting
us so
it's not exactly doing what we want
because we're doing chick less than
input number of chicks
it's not actually giving us the same
value and this is actually happening
before we did this it just we didn't
notice it actually didn't count the
lines
so we should go into chick wait
YouTube
and start
as well as I integer
might be right
there we go now it's all fixed
but we can do all of that you know we
can mess with our code we can update our
plots and all we have to do is just go
back and forth between the UI editor
and the code
um and so the idea is
you don't have to sit there and Fiddle
with this you know grid card what's the
argument name how do I you know where do
I Nest this I want to put it over here
yeah you don't need to worry about that
you could just focus on
writing good data science you know doing
correct plots you know doing your D
plyer pipes properly we want you to
focus on those issues which are
straightforward and not this like you
know crazy world that is how do you get
your text to align properly uh in your
UI how do you make your header a little
bit taller than it was before that's
stuff that doesn't influence how good
you are as a data scientist
um so we're trying to make that as easy
as possible you know before we talked
about like if we had a table
right
um
so we have like
code here
take that
come here and we use outputs
excuse me
and then
you actually put that table in here
so to go into the script card that has
nothing in it and we say
cheat sheet and it's like GT output
so
this idea of like you know we have a
table in here
we want to make it bigger so we can
actually see the table
we have this table in here
um but the UI editor doesn't support
doesn't have you know doesn't know about
JT tables yet
and so what it does is it gives you this
um little gray box that says hey I have
this UI function that I don't know about
here's the code
you can't edit it because I don't know
about it but it is treated just like any
other node and so you could take this
and put it up here
you know like and drag this down and so
now your tables from there so you can
like treat it just like you would any
other node
um
but uh it doesn't know about it and so
the idea there is that we don't limit
you know if you have some you know
cool custom function or just a function
that's not included yet it's not gonna
make it so you can't use the UI editor
um it just means that you won't be able
to use an icy editor settings panel to
change it
um
but you can still lay out your app and
everything and place it where you want
within the app
um
and then see what it is so I think
that's that will help you know ideally
in the future
every possible thing that you put in
your shiny app is known but I don't
think that's ever going to be the case
um and so this is how that is treated on
the other side that's
important to know